la pression s'intensifie également sur
odessa le plus grands ports d'ukraine
sur la mer noire c'est un point
stratégique pour les russes dimanche la
ville a subi ces premiers bombardements
julie d'une golf vous êtes sur place
pour france 24 à odessa les attaques de
l'armée russe viennent surtout de la mer
oui tout à fait hier cinq missiles ont
été tirés de la mer par l'armée russe
sans pour autant selon le commandement
opérationnel du sud du pays atteindre
ces cibles selon ce commandement et je
cite il s'agirait plus et bien
d'attaquer psychologique pour
déstabiliser la population n'a pu
s'entretenir avec des autorités de la
ville qui est veulent afficher une
certaine confiance quand il parle aux
journalistes ils nous disent qu'ils se
sont qu'ils se sentent prêts ils sont
convaincus d'une chose c'est que pour
l'instant eh bien les russes peuvent
continuer à attaquer par la mer mais qui
ne peuvent pas prendre le contrôle de
dessin pour la bonne et simple raison et
bien qu'il reste un verrou stratégique
un peu plus haut à 130 kilomètres d'ici
dans la ville de nicolas yves nicolas
yves qui subi des bombardements
importants une ville dans laquelle nous
avons pu nous rendre il ya quelques
jours avec amaral à mehdaoui où vous les
sirènes résonnent constamment mais pour
l'instant et bien les forces ukrainienne
résiste dans cette ville est temps que
les forceraient ukrainienne résisterons
et bien les russes ne pourront pas
bénéficier d'appuis au sol donc une
pression qui s'intensifie sur odessa
mais ici les autorités et bien remercie
tous les jours les combattants amicaux
live notamment le maire de la ville
remercie tous les jours les combattons
amis collègues de continuer à résister
car selon lui cela leur permet de mieux
se préparer en cas d'une éventuelle
attaque plus importante justement
comment se préparent les habitants la
population de dessin est ce qu elle les
gens cherchent à fuir au contraire
restent à odessa pour défendre la ville
écoutez il ya une partie de la
population qui est parti dès le début de
la guerre mais il ya aussi une grande
solidarité à peu près la même chose que
ce qu'on a pu entendre dans le reportage
un peu plus tôt de james andré et janet
ann walsh par exemple regarder derrière
moi ici c'était un ancien lieu très
branchée de la ville un marché un food
market comme on peut la plaie est bien
temps c'est un centre opérationnel des
opérations humanitaires c'est une vraie
fourmilière on voit des jeunes de tout
âge en train est bien de trier des
médicaments de recevoir des dons
d'organiser la logistique de vérifier
selon les soldats ont besoin au front et
puis d'organiser et bien leurs
livraisons par exemple un homme me
disais tout à l'heure que pour et bien
loger les réfugiés dire pin ou d'autres
villes et bien le fallait délit alors
qu'ils étaient en train et bien de trier
les lis qu'ils avaient à disposition
pour ensuite les envoyer un peu plus
loin cependant ce qu'on ressent ici dans
la ville d'odessa c'est que depuis la
première attaque de dimanche une
certaine inquiétude règne davantage au
sein de la population il y a un peu plus
tôt dans l'après midi nous avons pu nous
rendre dans un quartier très résidentiel
de la ville et là une nouvelle sirène a
résonné dans la ville ces fameux sirène
que l'on entend beaucoup en ukraine et
qui demande à la population d'aller se
mettre à l'abri et bien là on a pu voir
des femmes et des enfants descendre dans
les catacombes de la ville il fallait
descendre 20 mètres nous les avons
suivis et là c'est une véritable vie
souterraine qui s'organise avec des lits
des conserves de quoi tenir plusieurs
jours en cas d'attaqué très importante
est ce que nous disent beaucoup de gens
avec lesquels nous avons pu parler à
odessa et bien c'est que plus ils
entendent le sou de ces sirènes plus
intenses et de bombardements et bien
bien sûr plus l'inquiétude monte pour
eux je lis d'une gueule à fond en direct
d'odessa merci beaucoup